vulcans use a technique called colinar
to suppress their emotions
till then they're here obviously i
wasn't a vulcan so i did the next best
thing
took my feelings and shoved them down so
far they may have been lost
forever hi sheldon release of emotions
mr sparkers
what keeps us healthy dr mccoy was an
idiot
since we'll be spending a few hours
together i've created a list of
activities to keep us occupied
we'll start with a tour of my room then
board games and if time permits you can
look at and not touch my trains
my little pony i love my little pony
that's my sister's and it's not part of
the tour i share a room with my
sister too super fun you're wrong
now over here we have my desk this is my
computer
that's my mouse this is my printer this
is the paper that goes in the printer
this is a box of extra paper that also
goes in the printer
and this is my signed picture of
professor proton
do you watch a show no i don't really
like it
you don't i think he's boring
and he dumps everything down come on
colenar
don't fail me now and next on the tour
we have
a lamp you could play traditional chess
or if you're interested we could play a
variant with the new piece i invented
that sounds fun what's a new piece
a wizard the wizard cannot be taken and
at any point he can teleport and switch
places with any other piece yes but
there's an obvious flaw
what flaw well anytime anyone is
checkmated they can simply have the
wizard and their king switch places so
the game will never end i knew that you
passed my test
you actually believe the multiverse
theory very much so
it's the most elegant interpretation of
quantum mechanics
so you really think there are an
infinite number of universes
stephen hawking believes it so yes i do
well if there are an infinite number of
universes
i think that theory is dumb in all of
them
this is fun i don't get to have
discussions like this with kids at my
school
do you no
do you ever wish you were just like
everyone else
not at all me neither i love being
smarter than everyone
me too i started to think that paige and
i might have more in common than i
thought
maybe my mother was right i really did
just need to get to know her better
checkmate you lose red alert
phasers stand by the fire on my order
yes that makes me the smartest
i don't know if ten-year-old spock ever
flipped a chess board but 10 year old
sheldon sure did
[Music]
you